e aí
e a gente precisa aprender a valorizar
um lugar é claro que esse termo tem um
conceito muito maior do que esse trago
aqui e a minha intenção não é de forma
alguma fumantes ar isso mas vou pegar
ela emprestado para gente trocar algumas
ideias hoje bom segundo a revista exame
uma família pobre leva cerca de novas
gerações para atingir uma renda média e
sair do estado de pobreza logo tá
dizendo esses dados para nossa realidade
concluímos também que grande parte das
famílias negras demoram novas gerações
para sair da pobreza jack 75 por cento
dos núcleos familiares pobres são negros
é é verdade que esse dado aqui com tanta
em que você pode parecer enorme gritante
só que eu preciso te dizer tão bem que é
verdade que as aplicações práticas de
cidadãos são muito visíveis no nosso dia
a dia na minha vida na minha família foi
possível escapar desse dado dessa
estatística graças ao políticas
afirmativas
a educação e do afeto de pessoas negras
que estiveram na minha caminhada é claro
que eu como mulher negra tem que correr
para escapar de tantas outras
estatísticas tão cruéis quanto e aqui
começa o meu problema de um lugar como
algumas pessoas da minha idade quando a
gente começou a faculdade o nosso
objetivo usaram os mais simples os
formais especializar a trabalhar em
grandes empresas e tudo bem só que
quando eu comecei a conviver um
pouquinho nessa realidade nesse cenário
tudo mudou
e eu senti aqui por mais criativo que
esses espaços fossem nome contemplavam
não me recebiam é não contemplavam a
mesma individualidade e impediram que
pessoas como eu tivesse em voz nesses
lugares e foi aí que eu percebi a força
de empreendedorismo negro como um local
de resposta a esse sistema e como um
lugar onde pertence de resistência tá
ter uma ideia segundo o sebrae a cada
100 brasileiros negros adultos 40cm
entendedores é muito louco mais uma
frase que traduz muito bem a realidade
desse dado vem de monique evelyn ela
fala que o que os dados as estatísticas
chamam de empreendedorismo a gente chama
de sobrevivência já que o mercado de
trabalho é racista o suficiente para não
absorver esses profissionais ainda que
muito muito qualificados pessoas como eu
e outros nos encontramos tanto dentro
quanto fora do assunto predadorismo com
o mesmo sentimento de cansaço se a
é ético se matar 10 vezes trabalhar 10
vezes para tudo tem que ser para todo
mundo ou apenas não sei nossos
parâmetros são os mais atualizados para
tudo a cada segundo o aplicativo a gente
precisa da última versão a roupa conto
mais atualizada tendência celulares e
dispositivos nem se fala mas quando a
gente fala de pessoas de humanidade é
quando que a gente vai parar de se
contentar com uma estrutura que há mais
de 400 anos o prêmio as minorias um só
no mínimo ultrapassado para você
precisamos também parar de nos apoiar em
histórias de personagens negros de
sucesso que venceram e são utilizados
como estereótipos para que pessoas
privilegiadas não repensem seus
privilégios ea pisou em outras minorias
no discurso tão massivo esse tem tudo a
ver com o empreendedorismo é porque o
discurso empreendedor e se a construir
sobre isso eu peço licença para
generalizar um pouco só que assim que a
gente inicia o discurso
em qualquer coisa partir do mérito
estruturalmente a gente está excluindo
minorias que devem ocupar aquele lugar
já que a gente está falando do desejo
uma sociedade igualitária machado de
assis por exemplo negro mas quantos
jovens vivem com talento e sem
perspectiva para cada exemplo de vitória
pública existem outras mil personas
anônimas utilizam dos seus negócios e de
outros meios para resistir e criar suas
evoluções pessoais fecharam as portas
pulamos a janela mas isso não é só sobre
uma história feliz sendo muito
tendenciosa pela minha formação pelo meu
repertório eu acredito que as
transformações sociais que a gente tanto
precisa verão entre outros meios pela
arte pela educação pelos negócios eu
acredito demais na força preço desses
três elementos não entendimento minha
visão pessoal é que junto com o advento
da internet mandando informação no
segundo para o outro os artistas também
são os grandes responsáveis
o vetor sensibilizar e acordar as
pessoas para esse sentido para esses
assuntos e quanto a educação e os
negócios potencializam os despertar só
que o interessante é que maior ou menor
grau o fio que liga essas três áreas a
informação eu conhecimento isso é caro
isso do zé privado porque é mais uma
forma de opressão de minoria só que aí
que eu entro de novo como profissional
de comunicação meu compromisso comigo
mesmo é facilitar o caminho de outras
pessoas dentro do empreendedorismo e do
astro empreendedorismo através da
informação é sobre entender que enquanto
conhecimento de qualidade não chega para
todos é o meu dever levar essas pessoas
é devolver aquilo que eu recebi a gente
sabe que dependendo do tamanho do
negócio serviços de comunicação
marketing consultoria são completamente
fora de cogitação mas acreditam no que
eu acredito e sendo que o escurecer não
tem como olhar para uma pessoa que está
dando tudo de ser e vai sendo tu
o domingo feriado salário e sem
diferente a minha obrigação é trazer
essas pessoas comigo é seguindo e
compartilhamento e compartilhamento até
construirmos uma geração forte ainda
mais poderosa representativas entrada e
contrata pessoas negras crie espaços
democráticos diálogo de forma
anti-racista e que mudar a inúmeras
vidas através da minha é um propósito
que nenhuma planilha pode misturar e é
isso que eu vejo dentro de cada em
afronta prendedor é trabalhar para que o
afroempreendedorismo seja apenas
empreendedorismo sei que você entende
que eu quero dizer para finalizar é
válido destacar aqui que 52 por cento
desses empreendedores negros são
mulheres entanto considerável de garotos
que estão mudando o mundo gerando renda
querendo famílias que defendo o padrões
e você imagina o impacto que esses
negócios e base de pirâmide bem gerido
acompanhados e potencializadas
e nos próximos 10 20 anos a comunidade
negra de não lugar e não-lugar vem
criando seus próprios espaços de lucros
visibilidade tecnologias for se apoio o
meu não-lugar microsons parte
transformação bem maior do que eu esse
exato momento eu nem sei a conta de
quantas gerações já foram mudadas e
beneficiadas pelo pouquinho que eu faço
é que que eu escolhi investir se eu
puder deixar uma última mensagem para
você hoje eu acho que seria essa se você
ainda não encontrou o seu lugar acredite
tá no caminho encontro propósitos
compartilhe que você tem e deixe isso
reverberar porque o lugar vai te
encontrar